hey guys this is Reuben report i am dave
rubin and we have a smart heady showed
is that fair when you say before I even
say your names to the good people my
heading and he's smart smart and heady
rickover it's in ben mankiewicz two of
my favorites and we got a lot to get to
so let's do it a short time ago in a
boardroom close close to here Disney CEO
Bob either described last week's teaser
release for star wars the force awakens
as exciting promising eager moviegoers
the film will exceed their expectations
the CEO praised director JJ Abrams and
the new president of Lucas Films
Kathleen Kennedy for their respect to
pass film while pushing the storytelling
into the future they're attempting to
achieve the perfect balance between the
greatness of what was and the greatness
of what we believe is to come and I
think they have done that when people
see the film they will agree the film is
set for release on December 18 2015
alright so naturally we're starting the
show this week with clearly the most
important thing happening on the face of
the earth I am incredibly excited about
this almost everything I believe I
learned from Star Wars I even thought
the prequels were okay I get a lot of
[ __ ] for it Jar Jar Jar as I should as I
should all right so bad I gotta start
with you here as the movie guy uh do you
have the faith in the force that I have
with this thing I have a lot of faith in
in in JJ Abrams um I think the odds are
that it will deliver that fan base
apparently as evidenced by what you just
said will literally watch anything yeah
so you know it seems like it'll be
better that trailer has the feel and you
know as a as a as a movie critic you you
don't wanna make any bold decisions
based on a trailer 1 people will laugh
at you into you're gonna be wrong yeah
but come on be wrong right daddy I'm it
looked good you know it looked like it
was taken seriously didn't look like a
joke I saw Star Wars three times in 1977
like everybody else of of my age but
that second and third time I was like
yes we're gonna see Star Wars again cuz
this is what we do cuz we're 10 yeah but
i am not that into this really and it is
now
ever meant anything I didn't see the
Empire Strikes Back for 15 years after
came out I saw the first I saw the third
and then I had to cut a piece in my ear
I call yourself a movie review that is
disturbing Rick how do you feel about
this thing do you think ok so the
prequels everyone gets it they weren't
as good this was George Lucas directing
all of them after writing all the Mets
etc but now JJ Abrams I'm sitting in the
theater some middle-aged guys around me
roughly my age I'm 60 isn't that like
you go guys gray and I'll sitting there
waiting for the movie to start and they
bring out the trailer and these old
party old guys I'll go what's this and
then he either going along the water and
then we could put little bit look oh
look at and then you see then Harrison
Fargo's sure way or a home that's a good
Harrison for our special wait that was
Harrison who Chewbacca that laughs now
let you back i'm doing a joker now he's
old too but he isn't he looks exactly
he's got you know just for just for
wookies they didn't change that suit at
all no yeah so your point is that they
don't exciting I haven't seen grown men
cry like that since ray can sell is dad
came out of the cornfield that was a
movie um alright so the Disney part of
this uh but you know look Lucasfilm was
huge it started small and it became
something huge Disney's even bigger than
that is this just mean more toys this is
me more mainstream it's probably both I
mean look Disney they there they haven't
had what is it now you know 65 years of
enormous success by accident they know
what they're doing they are professional
movie people uh and this needs to be a
professional movie and if that in this
by the same token we're gonna get
blasted with more Star Wars stuff yeah
okay my cynicism about that has been
completely eroded by reality like but
this is the world we live in and that's
what's gonna happen but the important
thing is what kind of movie they gonna
make like if your blasted with product
placement and and and kids are inundated
with Star Wars stuff to buy and video
games that they'd then go with the
the first three movies the prequels well
then then yours then your appropriately
cynical about it you know I would I
don't think any of us were cynical I
certainly wasn't even though and I like
the Star Wars merchandise the little I
had the little action figures yeah um
and those were great I like those a lot
better than I liked the the first three
movies what do you think about the
Disney part of this you think there's a
risk in having just two or three studios
that own pretty much everything I mean
they own all the Marvel stuff now it's
all coming out of the same factories
what I sure was surprised when they took
a gamble guardians of the galaxy which
was like a really not at the same size
franchise by any means and they dumped a
ton of cash on it it will be running
neck and neck with guardians of the
galaxy I think those will be two
competing forces do you think that it
will ever come close to catching up I
know toys why's it hasn't what's
interesting about Star Wars though with
what is that you talk about those those
older men sitting up and taking notes
coming out yeah coming out of there all
right it was me coming out of their hot
coming out of their heart disease free
at the moment that's what guardians of
the galaxy is up against is this is this
multi-generational penetration that star
wars there's it's enough money for
everyone there's plenty of money real
quick so is that what captured your
imagination the way that Star Wars
clearly captured mine is there something
that did it for you Star Wars completely
it framed so much what I think about
things in 6m yeah thousand and one yeah
alright promised me a decade ago there'd
be a civilian space station and that
there would be Pan Am airlines and I
have been completely betrayed by my
culture yeah I would like to know I
mentioned this on Twitter and I didn't
get nearly as much hate as I thought it
would but it is a little weird going
back from the first movie and apparently
from the trailer that when the x-wing
fighters or whatever they when they
shoot in tunnels at the ships in front
of them and they miss there's never that
thing never hits anything like there's
never an explosion further down the
tunnel you mean of where the ricochets
and the
random shot gonna hit something actually
your there's no ping ping right you know
right that's a little complaint so I
guess your answer then is no nothing
capture imagination because you're so
literal and you want such truth what
captured your imagination the way Star
Wars captured mine let us know in the
comments right down below area man
really really really hates cable news
Jon Stewart claims the upcoming
presidential election pushed his
decision to leave the Daily Show which
he has hosted since 1999 after covering
for presidential elections over his
16-year rain stuart claims he just
wasn't getting the same level
satisfaction from hosting as he once did
he explained to the Guardians that quote
these things are cyclical you have
moments of dissatisfaction and then you
come out of it and it's okay but the
cycle has become longer and maybe more
interest and that's when you realize
okay I'm on the backside of it now
Stewart went on to acknowledge the daily
grind of major news channels like Fox
and MSNBC watching these channels all
day is incredibly depressing I live in a
constant state of depression I think of
us as turd miners I put on my helmet I
go in mind Turks hopefully I don't get
third lung disease Trevor Noah a
30-something South African comedian will
take over the reins of the Daily Show by
early 2016 there you go so John is
leaving The Daily Show Trevor Noah
taking over we're all in the news biz
thing here we talked about the news a
lot we tweet about the news we know
what's going on in the world how how
much do you empathize with that he had
to be in this thing constantly it's it's
a suck isn't it a soul sucking thing at
some level imagine being the host of a
local show for 10 years with all the
same faces in the audience looking back
at you for the do new material every
time you face them yeah locally you'd go
crazy from it you'd go completely but
you'd burn out from the thing you love
yeah I get it I get it and you know what
a new people will come in and take the
reins that's the way it was he was a new
person who took the reins and slowly
usurped it all faith in cable news away
to his show rather than theirs you've
done local news and The Young Turks and
plenty of other TV stuff how much of
just having to know about this stuff and
still perform and be out there and say
what you think like that it just takes a
certain toll on you
let me say one thing first uh my mother
a real progressive woman the only person
I've ever heard use the word usurp it
except in regard to late 19th century
European powers right but uh so uh I you
know I don't think there's any there's
no you know this is without conspiracy
theory that red incredibly true you do
something almost anything that long that
requires that much investment uh unless
it changes and as Rick said it doesn't
really change is the same kind of thing
you've got a sort of make change out of
what is the same kind of story again and
again you know right it was Rick
Santorum in 2012 and now it's Ted Cruz
but they're saying the same young
spirited hideous thing um and yes oh i
think it's a it's it's legitimate and i
don't buy an idea that he they pick
Trevor Noah so he'd fail so store would
look you know that's all it really is
over there so that's what I heard from a
couple of people no boy I don't wear
Twitter but why does Jon Stewart need to
be more validated like it doesn't matter
traffic Jon Stewart he's good you know
not Craig Kilborn Jon Stewart is the
godfather that show Jon Stewart made
that show what else and when you make a
movie that's pretty good and you you
know and you enjoy it and it was kind of
an important movie like you know he can
say i don't really know that my thinking
about that right now but he was i
guarantee you he wants to direct some
more movies he was he was pretty good at
and directors get better as they go
along yeah i would imagine that's
exactly what he was to be to your point
about how the show turn i interned at
the Daily Show in 1999 when Craig
Kilborn had just left and Comedy Central
was barely a network at that time I mean
not only did they build this show into
an institution but they built the entire
network how important do you think is is
satire in the political scheme of things
you know our friend jimmy dore always
says this thing about how Chuck Todd
admitted on Meet the Press that if he
ever asks a hard question the guests
will never come back so we need satire
more than ever right to call out the
[ __ ] because the media is never
going to do it right that's it bill
maher still holding down the fort you're
holding down the fort new voices will
rise up and fill in the knee
he did the demand for it is now going to
create its own march on so that's it
that's a beautiful thing right right
yeah that's a it's a yeah it's totally
beautiful thing it's it's it's but you
know it's it's it's vitally important um
and you know he this creating that it
was amazing is that he is that idea that
is too easily dismissed but that show is
more trustworthy than almost any other
show on on cable lose I'm worried for
Trevor Noah just because anybody
stepping in to that kind of expectation
is tough me that's a that's a tough
thing to do even if you're great at it I
mean you know I at the TCM festival any
of you George Lazenby who is a
interesting guy a a crazy guy and not a
little misogynistic um and uh but but
taking over for Sean Connery yeah was
impossible and that movie on her
majesty's secret service which was it is
great now great it's a great body might
be my favorite Bond it's one of the top
three but it was an impossible task to
replace Sean Connery and it might be an
impossible task to replace Jon Stewart
on the daily show ya a Trevor Noah might
be the guy who was like who was the guy
in between Jon Stewart and that whoever
this next guy is who was I hope not I
hope he perhaps dave rubin perhaps dave
rubin said just to be clear sir is there
a different day of rubery talking about
you guys vanna the day room in the
casting director actually to that point
i did text my manager the day that jon
said he was stepping down and I said can
I get on a list or an audition you're
saying he wrote back LOL so i don't
think we're gonna be working together
anymore anyway what do you think is john
going to go up and do great things and
is Trevor know we're gonna be alright as
the Daily Show host let us know in the
comments right down below cord-cutting
isn't just umbilical anymore the
televisions popularity as the go-to
entertainment device may be ending
according to a research report from
accenture according to the report TV was
the only product category to see
double-digit usage decline among viewers
of nearly all ages being rapidly
replaced by anytime anywhere players
such as laptops tablets and mobile
phones
[ __ ] for long-form video content such as
movies and television on a TV screen has
declined by thirteen percent over the
past year while sports viewership on TV
screens declined by ten percent gavin
man eccentric broadcast leave explained
TV shows and movies are now a viewing
staple on mobile devices thanks to
improved streaming and longer battery
life the second screen viewing
experience is where content creators
broadcasters and programmers will
succeed or fail so we've done a bunch of
stories on this I'm fascinated by this
topic because everyone still wants to
get to television yet you guys are
watching this online right now we know
the future is online but as a as a TV
guy do you think what do you think the
battle the battle front is going to be
at is it going to be the second screen
thing where the home will always be on
television but you'll still you'll be
doing something else on your iPad the
whole time is there some land I mean I
need the evidence here to be ugly more
anecdotal like I need to see how that
works I mean I it's not like I don't do
it is not like I don't watch a movie and
then look at IMDb and remind myself
who's in it so I guess I'm doing it that
it um but it keeps you keep talking
about 14 to 17 year olds who do it I
don't know what they're doing like what
what is it they're doing well they're
they're just not consuming tell they
don't me okay turning on television when
they get home from school the way we may
have all turned on television they me
there just walk around for a couple
things here that are that were left out
of that little report that are important
i'm a big sort of defender than in tv's
fighting strikes like it's not gonna
reverse right it's not gonna gain coming
back right but my hunch is there's a
plateau and it's still gonna be a lot of
people watching television even though
the future may be here and the
disappointing thing is that that the
communal aspect of television yeah it
passes i hope stays i mean because we
know we're not gonna talk right now that
so that's out this is the only time i
talk all day actual but if you like the
idea you know those were those were
countrywide moments the moat you know
Ben everybody gather around a watch
Seinfeld and and and let alone the drink
every at you're sitting next to the
dresser sit next to the Drake that's
right and everybody loves the great let
alone everybody that let alone every
single episode of
every every single Super Bowl every
single big sporting event so and that
you know at least when it's your tablet
or your I was this weekend i watch an
NBA playoff game on somebody's
smartphone with six guys it was a joke
oh god you know we're all like yeah I'll
bet uh so I don't know I I there is
still gonna be a sense of community
viewing yeah and television has a big
role in that although sometimes that
just maybe obviously the television
screen and watching Netflix or Amazon
Prime yeah on it Rick do you think
there's something to be said for not
being able to get everything on demand
the second you want it you know what I
mean even though television is going
that way too because you can get stuff
on demand on TV obviously as well but do
you think there's something to be said
for the old school Oh at eight o'clock
friends is coming on and we're all
watching it together tonight to draw the
parable two nite club comedy and it it
had its rarity factor dug in too deeply
by a digital media world where they can
also videotape you off their phone
quietly from their table while you're
breaking a bit in yeah put it on YouTube
killing any desire to see it in its
refined form later when I some workshop
and I don't need to pay to see the
finished one yeah you know and so admit
it has eaten up the the rarity factor
which you know exclusivity and rarity
bring up the price of a thing another
part of that piece that I think is is is
is important to note is that the trust
factor of people is still in the content
provided by the known entities yes and
that's so maybe television isn't going
to be i'm watching friends at eight
o'clock and and and wings at eight
thirty and give me what work come on
cheers at nine no no matter what years
and I did night corded 930 a lot Wow NBC
1981 so that's so that's that's gone but
they still want to watch that that if
NBC can still produce friends and cheers
an LA Law notice when I left out there
um the uh uh you know there's still a
market for that
just won't be at ten o'clock on
thursdays but you know you that that's
still what people want to see and there
are still only going to be if uh a
limited number of entities that can
produce that kind of quality i think
what this tells you is that the idea of
to quote springsteen 15 years ago or
business 57 chan more than that 20 years
ago 57 channels and nothing on now 357
channels nothing on we probably cannot
sustain that many channels we got did
these stats have to mean that some
channels are just gonna go away i would
think yeah bring some pay to have to pay
all that money originally cable the
whole point of cable was no commercials
it's all commercials now it's all coming
right nothing but commercial except i'll
turner classic movies every movie as it
was meant to be seen uncut commercial
current turner classic the good stuff
it's almost as if someone here works for
its better classic movies i'm actually a
big fan of turner clip anyway what do
you guys think are you cutting the cord
are you okay with staring and everything
on your small device let us know in the
comments right down below God is almost
done picking his 2016 fantasy team Ohio
Governor John Kasich continues to hit as
interest in running for president but
says he's waiting on a sign from God
before making the call Kasich who is
eyeing a slot in the GOP primaries
opened up on NBC's Meet the Press
reasoning my family is a consideration
but the most important thing is what
does the world want me to do with my
life however Kasich isn't just going to
wait around for a sign he's been active
on the trail just in case as one of the
five Republican governors considering a
bid for the presidential nomination
including scott walker chris Christie
and rich Snyder okay so it seems to me
that what a crazy person would do is
wait for a sign from God to do something
often murderers isn't that what a lot of
murderers do they get a sign from a dog
which is just God's fell backwards or
something like that to do say but that's
what this man is actually waiting to be
is waiting for God to go you should
press the thing but that's a good but no
no he's not and that's what's that's
what's almost worse like if you were
waiting for God to give him aside like
Sarah Palin or Ted Cruz who I think may
be legitimately think they get sides
from God
some others then I would be more willing
it wouldn't be quite as cynical it would
just be crazy John Kasich is by all
accounts not even in the totally lunatic
realm of the Republican Party but they
all have to be if they're running for
president so is to pretend this guy
honey has to pretend even and dismisses
his family but I'd be like dad [ __ ] off
no ask me yeah for some solid and then
going through but no I'm still gonna
visit Iowa New Hampshire just in case
God hasn't made up his mind yet I mean
it's but he's Andrea yes you cannot win
unless you pan so is that everything
that's wrong with politics right there
he has to get through a primary which is
basically just an exercise and who's the
craziest and he has to do that just so
that he can then bring all those
positions back at some level right this
is the classic comeuppance moment in the
horror film where the mad scientist that
built this giant dangerous stupid
stomping monster is working the remote
control and it's coming out of my back
and the remote doesn't work anymore and
now it's coming for him yeah back I told
you he can't control so that's what the
monsters coming for him at the thing
that was supposed to make life easier
for them by breeding this generation of
remote controllable people now is
backfiring because of all the dogmen
edict with those people they all want
him to look like he's standing by yeah
we get the legit people it interesting
people who seemed interesting in that
party are instantly no longer
interesting when they run for president
Rand Paul yeah was causing at least some
progressives at some point to be like
huh if I had a gun to my head and had to
vote for republican i think i could
maybe vote for that guy not now how is
increase in defend the things that made
him interesting he's completely
abandoned yeah i would refer Rand Paul
might be last on my list now and then a
guy like Marco Rubio who comes out is a
he's young like Obama a new senator like
Obama and then has an actual interesting
idea about immigration the brakes with
his party oh I ate it was more than the
other guys yeah now he just seems dumb
so what role I get it we're la elitists
here so it seemed like on send bad least
we have one la elite
here where were you know we're at but
you know um but that we are here so we
can watch this doesn't think it's
completely bonkers but obviously Kasich
is talking to someone he's either
talking to the people that believe that
he's talking about orie to some people
that want to hear it as you're saying
earlier how many of those people
actually exist anymore it's art it's
hard to tell enough to make a difference
in Republican primaries I mean you know
we've seen I mean that was a you know
that was a those it was an audience that
cheered to the death penalty that
cheered that Buddha gay soldier yeah
these are bad these guys are bad
Americans they're bad for the country
they do not reflect the ideas that made
this country great remember that
everyone who's gonna run who who would
be honest who would say like no God's
not asking me to run I'm practical I
want to reduce spending I want to have
the budget balanced it's a big thing for
Kasich constitutional Mehmet balance the
budget who is gonna say the words Jon
Huntsman like hey know a guy tried that
and he was a joke and he never got more
than two percent of the vote and now
he's not even in the party Jon Huntsman
real quick when they were due when he
ran last time and I was tweeting about
all the the debates and everything the
only joke i could make about him was
that he seemed like he was being held
hostage by crazy people because that's
because he was actually saying and
shouldn't have been like a cold one he
was actually a decent guy but he's not
running unfortunately anyway what do you
think do these guys just have to pander
is our system so broken does God have a
place in politics let us know in the
comments right down below shocker
America really really loves guns a new
pew research poll shows sixty three
percent of americans now the lead having
a gun is the best way to protect against
crime with the support for gun control
at a 25-year low if you suggested that
the changes the result of americans
believing that crime is a big problem
bite statistics showing the opposite
according to Pew
unclear why public views on crime have
grown more dire so many blame it on the
nature of news beverage reality TV and
political rhetoric yeah we love guns
we've always loved guns no matter how
many people are killed by guns no matter
how many children are killed in
elementary schools no matter how many
shootings there are you know after
Newtown it sounded like maybe we were
going to get some gun control something
like quote me I think we've talked about
this on tyt something like ninety
percent of Americans wanted stronger gun
legislation after that somehow that
couldn't get past what what is our
fascination with guns well you don't
have to be correct to have when you have
a gun you make everybody agree with you
by pointing a gun Adam then they all for
you force people to pretend that you're
right and so a lot of people can get to
be wrong and powerful as opposed to me I
just have to be correct I'm unarmed so
as to be armed with what I'm saying in
the meaning of it but you can stop and
you can any of your dogma can be made
correct the the one with the gun doesn't
have to be right he just has to have
what he's already got the one without
can scream and shout but even if he's
right he still gets shot guns we love
guns right i mean this country just
loves gun obviously look again i work
for a network that celebrates classic
Hollywood but but classic Hollywood
played a role in the gun fascination I
mean the most popular movies there in
the nineteen thirties and then into the
40's with the war movies but the
thirties with the westerns the guys we
idolize the heroes they weren't guys
with the best ideas they were the guys
with the biggest guns now you know
theory they were again generally the
guys on the just side but you you made
your case by shooting people by killing
people and you needed a gun to do it uh
so that it's we've been fascinated with
guns for a long time and obviously we
want our freedom by by using guns and
and and beaten the British I mean it is
the media it is the NRA funded media it
is not just fox news but uh local news
stations across the country I worked in
local news for five years that
expression there's never been a bigger
cliche that is more true that if it
bleeds it leads that is one hundred
percent true yeah what about single
person shooter games yes sir you know I
don't know I don't buy that I'll buy
lemonade they've had many
saying that that's not true I play a ton
of video game people say it all the time
I know but whatever not like well I
don't know i mean i don't know III don't
know yet i got it that i don't think
that because first of all single person
shooter games have increased and as
we're trying to get the point across
islands and crime are going down right
so that would indicate that maybe the
guns don't an outlet it might be an
outlet or were smart enough to know the
difference yes perhaps more likely
what's worse is the coverage of the
games is the conservative coverage of
game suggesting that this makes us more
violent again they love stories that
scare us the Republican Party has
succeeded for 25 years of scaring us
that black people are coming for your
white daughters gay people coming for
your white sons right uh the teachers
are gonna teach your kids how to be gay
the life that you knew and thought you
could control is being lost to other
forces people were different than you
Isis Isis is coming they're coming
across the Mexican border they're
leading prayer rugs down as they stream
across the board never just get through
the show none of it's true yeah we gotta
go man um so we're being scared
constantly on television reality
television and then the news which makes
I left local news because it made no
effort to tell people what was really
happening I went to a show that it did
and then no one watch um but it's pretty
hideous like they're you know they'll
cover politics they don't cover politics
interestingly when they do they just
cover the yelling and they basically you
know me if of a 7-eleven gets robbed
they'll cover that story and show that
tragedy without ever providing any
context that by the way the good news is
is that they'll probably catch the guy
uh and there hasn't the robberies like
this are significantly down since the
eighties massively down since cinta
Britt when it started really in the
nineties but these shows O'Reilly and
Hannity and Limbaugh and all these other
guys and to say nothing of local news
stations across the country thrive and
their success at least they think is
built on scaring us some crime scarce as
more than any right so is the irony with
this though then that despite all the
scare tactics which obviously exist
without question that despite all that
we the polls still show create a huge
percentage of people want more
ssible gun control despite that it's now
being compounded with a secondary set of
contradicting fear that even the certain
factions of the white community are
afraid of police now coming and shooting
their dog and shooting them on their
property and that a new thing that is
crossing because new videos are showing
some white people going under it and
it's activated the crowd that has all
these guns the white group that it
nothing worried about that that
happening to them that which is a first
yeah so that's interesting so it's like
it's the other thing they used to scare
you from the other now they're scaring
your government supposed to protect you
from the others now scaring them from
that side too so this two sites Karen I
think that's right fair fear is a you
know fear is so visceral the other stuff
is complicated and it requires you to
read fear is they're coming and like
this responds in so many easy ways to to
being men and being told that like EG
gonna protect your family or not yet you
know i'm a man i'll protect my family
but interestingly what we are prepared
for is i'm prepared to go buy a gun and
fill out a report how to do a complete
background check and get that gun in
seven days well i'm at least glad we
ended that with a little reason by the
way I'm for the Second Amendment you
should be able to have a gun but yeah
seven days you can wait a couple days
they're gonna do some checking and then
you'll get your gun you get all your
ammo and all that good stuff what do you
think about gun control let us know in
the comments right down below local
students form after school douchebag
club a group of students at a
Pennsylvania high school organized an
anti-gay protest by dressing in matching
flannels posting Bible verses on lockers
and wearing the word anti-gay on their
hands this protest came after a day of
silence a school event held to recognize
gay bullying students who participated
in the day of
event reported being verbally and
physically harassed by the flannel
wearing students the superintendent took
to a local news station addressing the
severity of this issue ensuring
necessary actions will be taken to
eliminate discrimination within the
school system alright so first off I
should just tell these guys that flannel
is a staple in the lesbian community so
they may have been dressing up like
lesbians or the Bears the gay bears
where a lot of flannel so that they
screwed up the the the dress code of
this club when the lumber jacket he's
okay yeah exactly was uh flannels back
among the hipster crowd like a hipster
latte yeah uh but so yes they created
this club we're just a couple dudes were
hanging out together we're and final
that seems kinda gay to me uh but cut
weight cut you know the footage of them
all you know circle jerking each other
that video comes out it's over that no
one not closeted hates gays that much no
one that's the rule you go uh you most
of all games at the city says in the
mirror every morning when he share okay
so that that's why that's basically the
whole crux of this whole story is right
like listen cause this is just said the
role it's the universal unavoidable rule
I don't think so I i I've but I thought
that a lot of the premise with that yeah
I but I argue this every time we've
we've had this debate before I think
that uh that uh you talk growing up
about to fear again we talked about fear
in another clip today to be afraid of
different and gay is different and gay
and we're afraid to talk about sex to
begin with so we're already timid in a
little Victorian about sex and then this
is the big sex thing right it's this is
really different uh and parents and
unfortunately uh pastors and all kinds
of youth leaders are telling these kids
that this is dangerous and somehow this
is corrupting so yeah I'm sure some of
these kids might be closeted but I think
there is a willingness and an eagerness
to hate and to defend the thing that
again your parents have told you was
slipping away the idea of the great
idyllic America when black people can
ride in the front of us you know uh
there was two black baseball players but
you know that that again they and they
already feel like they've
lost a lot like our with the blacks
already have their everywhere and
they're protesting they're angry all the
time why can't we take what's ours why
are they in Croke they're encroaching
they're taking for me even though
they're not I think it has I think that
as a a lot to do with it separate from
whether that what that whatever they
secretly feel at night when they're home
the beautiful part of the story I
suppose is that the internet exists now
and these kids uh can be exposed and
that this stuff won't ever Apple head of
posts next to the dead giraffe you're
done you [ __ ] you [ __ ] dunce you
just blew it while you're doing hey hey
look at I'd why is my life suck now why
my miserable and drinking cuz you showed
earth and you live in a bubble this big
you live in a Habitrail tool tube and
when you come out of that tube you see
how everyone's looking at you and saw
what you did their minds are being blown
they're all completely isolated but then
aren't you then bullying those guys
they're just trying to stand up for what
they believe in aren't you a big
left-wing bully I care less about
bullying then uh uh some people I like I
don't I think that part of it toughens
you up I think that when it's directed
at a specific group it's obviously
dangerous and schools need to do
something about it I do worry about
keeping these kids from expressing their
point of view but they need to be outed
oddly enough uh for being the sort of
vitriolic haters that they are notice
that there no girls doing that yeah
that's only these idiot guys on a double
little to be about seven or eight of
them and they and they you know and
BuzzFeed where I think that article came
from they tie lies the the photos of the
guys and I think that was the right
thing for them to do but in that
community mcguffey high school uh the UM
you know that everybody knows everybody
knows who they are yeah so yeah and
that's what they'll say because again
part of this thing is is if you're sort
of white and Christian and everything's
fine but you don't have quite as much
power and influence as used to the new
idea again echoed by by Fox consistently
and by limbo on the radio is that you're
the victims so these guys have somehow
felt because there was a Gay Pride Day
the day before where kids who are
different and it felt isolated most of
their life
stood up and said I just wanna I just
want to be able to go to high school and
be myself ask for nothing more to be
able to I school me myself that somehow
these guys have been led to believe
again by their parents sometimes by
lousy pastors and by mass right wing
media that somehow that is a threat to
their way of life leaving sick [ __ ] and
the whole anti-gay thing is just
basically they're useful idiots being
used to keep the production line moving
forward of new customers because gays
don't produce new Christians yeah even
though Christians continually produce
new gays are you a Christian producing a
gay let us know in the comments write
down to them everything's bigger in
Texas including their gay porn
consumption the Bible about leasing
estates and consumption of gay porn
according to the recent data from
pornhub com according to the websites
findings Mississippi leash the country
in gay porn viewership at five point six
percent not to be outdone Louisiana and
Georgia are close behind at five point
four percent on average every state in
the South watches gay porn at a higher
percent than the average of states were
gay marriage is legal so we just did a
segment which will link to down below
about these kids in high school that
we're forming an anti gay club Rick you
made the point that all of this stuff is
just based in homophobia it's basically
its base in the self is purely business
model mechanical dynamic of making
future customers for the business and
the gays don't reproduce at a rate
satisfactory to that business model and
so they manufacture hatred for something
that impedes their business and that's
all this is there just worker ants to
them you know and while they're doing it
they're consuming gay porn apparently
they're consuming gay porn in the states
where you're not supposed to be gay at
all yeah that means a lot of hidden away
stuff you know a lot of people not able
to quit each other most of this probably
reflects a bit of a a you know it which
you can identify with Dave some sort of
personal tragedy happening at that
moment cuz this is probably not it might
be some Crusaders against gays who
secretly go home at night but more
likely
because there are men and this is all
study a man they left out lesbians
because a lot of the lesbian porn is
probably watched by men uh but actually
write that I were joking but it's a good
way yeah i was aware that uh the uh but
um yeah that california's Alec
eighty-seven percent after Rick Overton
but you got early kids in the states
they mentioned Mississippi Georgia
Louisiana other states in the South not
even kids grown man the dangerous when
it's kids uh but grown men who are
afraid to be who they are and have no
outlet maybe don't date maybe don't even
are able to have intimate relationships
with other men and so porn is live porn
ography is literally going to be they're
outlet for that so I mean I see those
stats and that just there's a sadness in
that I think all yeah so it's really
it's a double-edged sword it's the
people that are forcing these laws and
the people that then can't act in
communities where you don't feel like
you can say you know what it turns out
okay right and yeah I'd love a hug but
you're not gonna get a hug you're gonna
get it uh you're gonna get shot yeah is
there anything that surprises you about
this then this it's pretty
straightforward right it's strangely
reassuring that there's an undercurrent
of or whatever humanity is trying to
become still going on it just looks like
these different things right now but it
seems like uh in 25 years Texas could be
an entirely different colored place yeah
or sooner it's happening rights breaking
apart Leo this means it's disintegrating
the old model like evolution does yeah
so where does this put the the gay
marriage thing for you because I'm sort
of okay with the way that it's been just
happening state-by-state if that's the
way it's gonna happen and that's the way
it's gonna happen for weed as opposed to
the the federal government coming in
just making a bits it didn't take that
long actually if you look at these last
couple you mean our government knee
stacked I think and I I mean I think
spring portal will settle it you know I
you know it yes it in a general in a
general sense having it happen
state-by-state is ok but there are gay
people living in that state and who that
don't have it that should be able to get
married and sure
they shouldn't have to leave Georgia and
move to maryland just because they you
know love a guy all right i don't know
that i can add anything else in that
well said guys what do you think gays
porn marriage there's a lot there let us
know your thoughts in the comments right
now above the neverending story reality
edition google executives have expressed
their desires to live forever but Ray
Kurzweil Google's director of
engineering has come out with his
specific plan to achieve eternal life
the 67 year old computer scientist
swears by his strict diet regimen of
fruits healthy fats dark chocolate and
up to a hundred pills pops every day to
promote brain sexual and overall health
Kurzweil explain the key to longevity is
eighty percent teens twenty percent
lifestyle but if you're diligent it's
ninety percent intersection and ten
percent jeans unfortunately Kurzweil
intervention isn't for everyone quite
yet the hundred pills add up to about a
thousand dollars a day alright we've
done a bunch of stories on Ray Kurzweil
I'm sort of fascinated by this because
we're living in the time right now where
it might be possible to live forever Ben
you laughed at when a reporter said
diligent because I don't think you're
that you're not diligent enough he's to
live forever he's crazy we're not living
at a time work maybe we can live forever
you don't think so you don't think that
this no 100 pillow eating right and good
no no of course not it's not gonna about
even debatable I mean what about Ponce
de Leon it wears water we're living in a
time where we live longer because
healthcare so good and we know how to
live better but he takes 100 bill 500
but it's down from he like 30 to 50 and
like it starts so normal you're like
healthy eating of of fruits and and dark
and something veteran good vegetables
and and dark chocolate you're like great
oh and a hundred pills a day at a cost
of a thousand dollars he hasn't figured
it out you didn't want to die a hundred
pills a day there's 24 hours a day so
that's about four pills basically for
pills an hour it seems like a lot it's a
lot of work when you want to do that
much work I'm not in a financial bracket
for my life to be that important that is
to say only above a certain thing do you
get to go to Elysium in orbit right
have the bad heal everything for you i'm
one of the work or class down here
there's coughs and falls over one day
yeah no I'm actually I'm trying to live
a little better you know there's another
Richard Overton there's a hundred and
seven years old that guy all right yeah
we'd look him here's he looks like he's
awesome and so there is a there is going
to a hundred now as a as a goal you know
and I am curious to see how all of this
turns out that what's gonna happen
though is you're gonna have really you
know we talked about the one percent the
ninety-nine percent out but you're gonna
have this rich level of people who will
have better health care better access to
food and water and all of that stuff and
at the end they'll be able to take all
these pills and there were just gonna
create this system where you're gonna
people that are living forever living
extended guerrilla and everyone just
dying off it is a lethal dose they're
made of us yeah the soil aren't so I so
y'all are ye keep reading about people
who are hundred seven rich is rich / do
you like your dad or no donate now know
is African American War veteran who
lives in Texas all that smokes a cigar
every day and he still drives entirely I
wanna shake his hand yeah right but not
to ours um yeah I think he could take
time but you know you read the stories
about the you know some one hundred
thirteen hundred fourteen year old
Japanese woman died you know not rich uh
doesn't seem like some of the stores
like my doctor just retired at a very
young age and he retired it turned out
not to really retire but to have
families Pam I'm slightly wrong on the
number fifty sixty or seventy thousand
dollars a year like 40 families they
paying that much money and then he just
he's there dr. any comes and you don't
pay anything else you said he comes to
your house or you go to his office and
he takes care your kids and all your
blood works free and like that's the new
he realized I can do this I have enough
client I suppose if you were worth 12
million dollars that that might be a
useful way to get medical care but
obviously that is a level of care that
the overwhelming majority of people are
not going to say we already have this
little bit yeah yeah I mean this guy has
how's he getting these pills you know
anyway would you even want to live
forever do we lose something that's very
human if
the thing never makes the full circle
let us know your thoughts in the
comments right down below I for one
welcome our new robot overlords meat ham
of humanoid robots that can smile Brown
week or even act drunk all but the fish
of a button wowing crowds at an
electronics fair in Hong Kong and very
head of facial expressions are
controlled by 40 motors these are
covered with the unique human like skin
called rubber short the flesh rubber the
ultra realistic Android can also
recognize and interprets the expressions
of real humans it comes into contact
with all right you guys know I love
these robot stories I love all the
future stories the creepy part of that I
thought the quicker you be part the
whole thing was pretty damn creepy but
rubber rubber flesh rubber all right you
know we just did a segment on living
forever you mock living forever been up
but robots will you at least concede
that robots are going to replace us yeah
I mean that to some extent talk about
health care as good as more people would
lose their jobs could lose I'm all for
uh you know that piece was like how much
we just show their a piece like a minute
fifty yeah I willing to the phone it's
not that good like because all like in
that story basically here's what we saw
the robot do like this is my camera we
saw the robot do like nine times like
that's a separate separate eyes like it
can win to a little more than Rand Paul
can do it is only right so I don't know
man I just like and I love that one of
the settings is drunk like the debate I
because that's what you do because the
future healthcare that's what you want
yeah p a robot yeah yeah yeah it's great
that they made his face look like one of
the guys robert downey fights with as
Sherlock Holmes and an alley somewhere
yeah its arms but isn't this how it
starts it starts with us looking at a
robot that's just a head on a table
blink in one way blink in the other a
dinette yes that is that was the hand
yes fine yeah these are
around that yes well that the they keep
not getting it to go very far icky he
got tangled up and confused like Siri
does and you're trying to find you know
like a place to eat descend into a gas
station uh that still are still really
simple we're being were being drawn in
by fake facial features uh the the more
popular model as the Japanese [ __ ]
robot it's gonna be all [ __ ] robot
email well that we've done stories on CS
by at the end of that piece in fact I
like for for health care that that that
they want to have it'll be of the robot
actually is a more approachable woman
yeah i mean i got like I mean it's like
he couldn't stand to do the story the
way I get and and and i'm sure that yeah
i mean it seems to be where it said it
anyway but I mean why why is the if it's
for health care yeah why is the female
more pro it's a robot right sorry Lori
couldn't make differs not real hey I'm
not this isn't gave our mail robot
you're gonna be representing would you
be jerked off by a male robot as a
heterosexual man only on a long drive
and oh what the hell we're not in Vegas
yet isn't all this just how we're
disconnecting ourselves from humans that
that's really what's going on here that
right now I just saw another story in
Japan this week they're having a bank
tellers that are robotic that you're
gonna you know it's not just going up to
an ATM machine and punchy of course
we're not getting humans anymore but
it's not just the ATM that you're really
gonna talk to one of these things and
that we're losing something that's just
very human the ability to sit with
someone and actually talk about
something and and the you know I come
from this local news background and and
I mentioned in an earlier segment but
you know we what we've lost is any sort
of authenticity you know with we have
the you know the the reality TV worked
in the beginning with survivor because
we actually felt like we were getting
something authentic I didn't watch it
but I saw a couple episodes and it was
not so much of a book on it um but then
like local news and the real news and
everything that we are sort of seeing
now is
fake the outrages fake were mad at
everything on the air everything is on
and so you know little things that
matter like again and an interaction
with a bank teller you know at least
it's really authentic and I I i I'd
enormously ballon the loss of
authenticity but what they're really is
going to be the loss of our jobs and
that's what this is I mean robots it's
fun you know when you think about robots
you like doing robots or as you like hey
it'd be great me and David will have a
robot in the house until like sweep up
and do that then what's david guetta to
do whatever and do uh uh that's funny
and do and do fun stuff and we gonna buy
the robots are kaiser and they're gonna
buy 375,000 of those robots yeah and
i'll let them fire 675,000 people yeah
um and those people will have to take
you know is blue they get the economy's
better and jobs are coming back but
those are good jobs that are coming back
and those people take lousy er jobs and
the disparity between the rich and the
poor yeah but we're mining on Mars right
so all the taxi drivers a robot drag the
but you know what robots they'd be
excellent wine Marsh miners total recall
one of my favorites anyway what was
appointed story what's your favorite
movie no robots are they coming to kill
us let us know in the comments right
down below alright that's the big show
I'm gonna let you guys pimp yourselves
out talk to the good people right over
there hey guys Northern California
friends on the twenty-eighth of April
I'm gonna be at the Throckmorton theater
so come on out for a fun Tuesday there
you go uh Ben mankiewicz of n make 77 on
on Twitter you didn't want everybody
have to fill out the whole spelling of
the name that's right don't wake Ben man
and also it's a way for people to think
get that guy have been born in 1977 is
he 38 I think is I don't know that
you're fooling anyone anyway thanks for
watching guys [ __ ] off you again next
week